today on our show I got a special guest
it's almost a solo assignment I remember
not quite because we got another boy in
fact kids what we're going to talk to a
godly person today right and do the come
back down on that mess thank you
that men on that man hey everybody it's
me mark barnard and kevin smith is not
here he's off doing Kevin smithy stuff
somewhere in the world I don't know
where I can never keep track of him but
I got a guest Michael Greene the
co-creator and Co showrunner of American
Gods and the man who was having the best
year in the history of years
welcome to the fat cave which is not the
fact cave today we're in we're gum and
villainy gum in hilly are we allowed to
say with its loosely inspired by a film
you may or may not be familiar with hi
in this space Cantina ish there may be
Blazers and there may be some sort of
foamy beverage with a frog in it for you
- yeah I mean right now if you're
watching the show you know what this
case is you know you know where it is
you probably been here and I've got get
thee to a cantina quickly I'm not going
to stop giggling this is epic we are
friendly and and I never have seen you
in person I'm doing I'm doing this
your zero stories and it's like you're
holding the karaoke mic so I feel like
you're actually proud I've heard those
stories of like Marilyn Monroe would be
out like out in the world trying to not
be Marilyn Monroe it kind of almost sort
of disguise it and I would say to
somebody wanna see me turn on and that
you just [ __ ] like that
yeah come ala Monroe here's my favorite
thing about that story is you just
compared yourself to Marilyn Monroe I am
I feel like I have the curves for it
I've been building this feminine body
for a while but you know all right I'm
sick so listen I we're going to talk
about I'm going to derail every attempt
you have it talking about actual work I
mean I welcome the derailment but okay
we're going to kind of we're going to
circle back a little bit we're going to
talk about merican gods we're going to
get there because absolutely because of
God you need to watch it you need to
watch because this is growing up on
Friday the finale of the first season
yes on Sunday or eight of eight eight of
eight eight of eight take that one again
is going to run and you can catch up on
them and you damn well should if you
have an ode show up Oh Cho and so we're
gonna spoil the [ __ ] out a little bit
I'm going to spoil it you know they
showed a trailer after the seventh
episode that was pretty much we were
watching it we had built the cast and we
were tweeting and Bryan and I just
looked at each other prime filler who
run the show it who should be here we're
going to be talking about it which is
the text it will be archived
we simply each other like did they just
do the whole episode
so you can just see the 45-second
version it slowly will pull brian in on
the view screen that we can activate in
the background just that would not rise
named Ken another herb can I touch in
Brian fuller and just Frank that's the
wrong franchise I know it's around
franchise [ __ ] you I do that okay so
let's let's go back to the very
beginning let's wait where does Michael
green begin what is the story of Michael
the book of Michael what is neither can
we just jump in like when I did anything
interesting we can jump ahead to here
yes if you want oh sure I guess there's
other [ __ ] you want to get in there
first sexual experience I oh I was
terrible well I was terrible and it took
years from like start to finish before
you could actually call it like that one
that counted me not if it took years
from start to finish I feel bad it was
not it was it was a process
and I was not involved you know it turns
out most of the time it's better if
we're not involved yeah that's a wonder
woman thinks we're not necessary for any
others yeah which is by the way yeah uh
yeah so tell me when you first knew you
wanted to be a writer
oh god it was more it was I always know
I want to be a writer of some kind but
it was trying to come up with a
definition of what the [ __ ] that meant
was like dr. Seuss at first like how to
make these fun odd I do not have an
interesting answer to likely where I
came from my David Copperfield story
it's like you know what did you come
from magic I was wrong Jeremy okay I was
born in the call like David Copperfield
was that the thing I'm not no good
I'm gonna click uh no I was one of those
just luckiest boy in the whole world
like guy wanted to write figured it out
enough to like write something that got
me something that got me my first job
and TV was a different animal than it's
a better animal now there's so much more
interesting but my first job first Joe's
Sex in the City
I was the staff writer on season one Wow
and just like quacked like a baby duck
whenever you know like I knew how to do
and you know I couldn't believe how much
freaky [ __ ] you know you hear slash say
in the room
it was no freaky it wasn't free it was
more just a chance to access like you
know the type of things you were always
told to cur because you can't do that on
television that that was suddenly fodder
you know it was the kind of things you
saved for your plays were now to be put
into a show and mind you I was 25 in had
no business like I no artistic you know
aesthetic at that point I got to work
with two incredibly talented people
Darren star Michael Patrick King and I
watch them work and I was like oh that's
how you break a story I want to do that
for 50 60 odd years and it was also
really fun being in something knowing it
was gonna be a big deal before anyone
would believe it like my parents friends
were like you're gonna give up working
in a fabulous real estate firm with your
father which is my dad and he's great at
it
to go work on a porn show on cable like
every boy's dream every boy's but at the
time like HBO wasn't it was before like
The Sopranos was like shot their pilot
from our offices with their production
office after we wrapped the first season
and so it was you know people only knew
HBO for him like reruns with the
Beastmaster in first and 10
dream on if you're feeling artsy right
all loved Arliss Oh a lot of lords fan I
can't I can't they can't could he play
love it on um and so home was Becky's
home Becky's yeah I'm straight out of
the box in New York do I suppose look at
you or like down the barrel I keep like
wanting you like it's hypnotic listen
you can stare wherever you like to stare
the people will stare back at use the
black mirror we know this okay
there are people out there I strongly
recommend anyone watching this turn off
youtube and watch listen to this on
audio they would this is Glory's visage
you got pronounce it wrong I'm a perfect
different every time I say it from now
on vez we they had you know that's
upstairs anyway so yeah I got into TV
and it was awesome it was a jump ahead
uh but yeah a very lucky first job to be
something as awesome as sexual city and
like just be able to say like no no
there's this terrible drink it's called
the cosmopolitan you're all going to
pretend to like it I like that that a
decent chunk of your career seems to be
like skittering over pop cultural
touchstones
and like you go from here you go from
touching the city a little bit of time
in the weeds I'm out of pop culture well
I remember it was my first it was my
interview on Smallville season 1 I
worked on smallville season 1 great
writers were in there and it was I was
in the the meeting where we just
shooting the [ __ ] and saying like hire
me look tap-dancing fart like they've
already read you in these meetings so
now they're just trying to see can I
stand you and an awesome date for like
four months
yeah if you're four it would be like
nine months of seven-day weeks with like
three meals and styrofoam
these are not all days where you've got
like 22 episode orders supposed to the
worst you know then but it was in that
meeting that I realized like oh wait I
have a reservoir of information that
trove is not a liability like it is on a
date or on other meetings that I can tap
into it I just like well look I'm not
the you know encyclopedia a lot of other
people are Jeph Loeb but but here's what
I know about you know and you and just
hear the books I read here are the
things I love and here's how I think it
can work into as a family drama is you
know get tapping into the teens and it
was it was fun and I'm like I can
actually you there's a gear I can I can
go through third were you a nerd from
like way back when like what what was
your nerd Oh entry point I wish there
was an easy answer I could just say like
an eighth I was educated I was so off
like the scales of what so I was
educated in the Jewish parochial system
this is like deep Jew weren't we all
this is this is like every morning when
and put on art fill-in and you know
yarmulkes all day boys praying in the
front girls in the back this is this is
some serious thing and like you know if
you had a crush on a girl her name was
rifki or tomorrow if you were lucky and
yeah there's got it going up so it was
also at my high school was a graduating
class of 27 people Wow so we didn't have
like the cool people and the nerdy
people in the jock and of it it was like
a jock running off beating everybody up
but there was like a kid who was better
at math like there was no we were all
such nerds that it was only like the
sliding scale among them so like you
know the tallest pygmy
kind of analogy none of us were actually
cool and we did up the presence of mind
- no that was like the public school
kids had a chance at cool we just had
the kids were in double Talmud and the
people who weren't in honors don't like
that was that was that was our ally so
um I came out of that just knowing like
ya know this was just a world like a
world of nerd and so what we read you
know we we watched our movies and read
our comics but we didn't have society
about it we didn't talk about it much it
wasn't until I started like writing
genre professionally that you know I was
around people who like oh this was there
this was their dialog this was their
lingua franca or like Oh Chris Klieman
like talking about the artists and the
writers and the incres and the letters
that they loved whereas I just read them
and didn't process them as literature
were you Marvel to DC kids both I was I
was spider-man Batman
okay body vote I'd like here allistic I
did arrive I didn't know enough people
to say that like like by two friends or
read comics you know we just made
characters it was sort of like it's like
if you talk to a sixteen year old today
and the you know you say like hey do you
know what network do you watch your
shows and they're like what's a network
you know like I watched Game of Thrones
unless my iPad and I watch you know this
is us on my iPad all shows up on my box
yeah so like what's an NBC so I I had no
real sense of his new spider-man and
Batman only hung out like in that
special issue behind glass but you are
never going to get to which I own no I
have like the giant size cross as one
must yeah why why I'll make money unless
you get [ __ ] that you did that I try to
interest my kids actually I broke the
seal on that just like if my daughter
was like so one of these do you never
mean I'm like well actually we're gonna
do soon yeah and it wasn't like a well
actually it was a you're gonna be
excited yeah listen you could either go
to college yeah well you could read this
book yeah so uh I run all that knowledge
was basically like anything spider-man
did like Marvel tales I even bought like
I was and I didn't I was reading those
not even realizing they were reprints
for him like 73 I that I was just I was
reading in a vacuum but I loved it and
it was the start you know I remember
when Batman legends Dark Knight happened
and it was oh wow stories over for parts
and that's the early experience I had
like
television structure of course in
television you need to actually figure
the story out by the last act but
sometimes they did um sometimes
television yeah it does sometimes
television legend archived early so it
was pretty sporadic reading so all of
this stuff would then come to play when
you get on Smallville I'm assuming not
much of this reared its head in Sex in
the City
no no no in second city it was just like
don't talk about that man don't talk
about that just don't pop your laws out
loud different don't say snitch just
don't yet it's not going to fly what is
that made of adamantium perhaps I was I
was I was flexing different muscles it
looked good the best work my favorite
work is where you get to flex them all
together so small go how long we're on
small go one year did six episodes and
it was exhausting and hugs and kisses
goodbye and that show went on for like
15 more years got blasted it did yeah
that's much like supernatural is now
it's amazing the bladder rocket and the
David Nutter pilots that go on forever
he's great okay so after Smallville Oh a
little bit of I would actually have to
look up IMDB right now somebody had a
little spinning genre thing I mean
you're trying to get me to here oh so
you come trying to be resisting me at
every turn you can you can get right
there I mean for people who are here for
the American Gods finale spoilers we are
taking these yeah we're gonna get the
slow boat you just [ __ ] wait we're
gonna get there taken listen okay so
heroes now it's it is it would be it
would be odd to not say that this thing
was a phenomenon it was it with yeah
that was I mean save the cheerleader
save the world was this thing that I was
working at in her said weekly at the
time and nobody was really prepared for
this to happen here at a place like eww
it's all about like forecasting what's
gonna be big you guys we know we have
the inside scoop and kind of nobody knew
because well it was I mean I thought
that just happened right so but heroes
was like comic books at superheroes yes
we've never heard of anything but it
could be a thing it was it was the
beginning of recognition that everyone
loves the [ __ ] and that the the fallacy
that this was for boys young boys and
something that Opie noted genres for a
subset was never true and we the writers
all felt that because we were people who
loved it
someone needs to do the panel of first
season heroes writing room it was an
incredibly talented group everyone on
there was a rock star and has gone on to
rock star work it's where I met Bryan
Fuller Jesse Alexander Jeph Loeb John
Petoskey haricots light Nataly China's
like everyone was brilliant and people
came on after were brilliant too but it
was a unique room to be in yeah it was
fun I mean there was the day where you
came in like oh [ __ ] we're a hit we were
right we gambled mid we were but there
was also the sad sad like writer
knowledge of we were having this great
moment but lost which was such a
brilliant show was having a second
season that people were [ __ ] on and
for no reason than because people like
to [ __ ] on things because it isn't shiny
and new right and we're just sitting I
remember even like on the great day of
like the first day ratings came in it's
like this time next year dudes we are
going to take it on the chin people are
going to be just like wow they're doing
the same tired [ __ ] or worse they're
changing it like no whatever
so um I mean what is it like dudes
outside of a room in the middle of that
Maelstrom where you're trying to just
keep telling her stories no no it was it
was fun it was we were it was the first
time we were all being rewarded for
taking the ideas that you had been
rewarded before for putting aside
because that's movie stuff we don't do
that here and just going what if we did
what if he had a sword in his back
whatever what if it's her time travel in
early like what if what if he just went
[ __ ] nuts and try and use your best
ideas instead of sidetrack them so that
was really fun it was exhausting because
we were working with a network and the
studio's NBCUniversal we're very
invested in the show they weren't the
like evil terrible people it was it just
wasn't something they ever made like
they were owned by GE and you know Tim
Krang would talk about you know created
heroes and staff that room we talked
about going to like GE things and being
at a table with someone who's in charge
of like washing machines and someone
once on a call with us like slipped out
do they refer to acts of the show as
entertainment units here we are you know
unit was not fun enough you guys help
the entertainment quotient of this
got to have something to do with my
Cherry's free meal on right so it was we
constantly had to just explain what we
were trying to do to people who'd never
seen anything like it never worked
anything like even serialized television
was just hard for them because
television broke down into procedurals
and soaps and and this was neither and
it would have been so you know they
rightly not rightly they just by habit
by just sheer education kept wanting the
show where when it again all me to the
whole justice the end of episode two
like what when does that happen like
have you ever read Bleak House no no we
haven't we were marketing people um and
so how long were you on here I was on
heroes for a season and change the
second season was kind of cut in half by
the writers strike I was going off to
work on show Kings that I written the
year before but was passed on by one
regime and picked up by the next and so
I helped out a portion of season two
which is a whole other TED talk we will
not get into the seasons where you were
not there because I have my feelings
about work I actually haven't seen them
it's the downside of working on the show
is you just you can't you can't watch
you can't watch anything ever after but
then you move on the kings and I have
sucked the dick of kings
almost every chance I get going we got
inches I mean all the way the back of
the throat no I've been like I've loved
the show that's how I met Mike yeah we
met for some you reach out to other
Twitter's because the Twitter's actually
casually bring people together and not
tear them apart but then I talked to him
about it because I'm a huge fan of the
show and if you've never seen it you and
my mom are the big fans
we are the these body of love and but
it's this modern-day altered history
retelling of the story of King David and
Silas and Goliath and all that stuff
it's a biblical a modern-day biblical
tale and it tackles all kinds of themes
of betrayal and love and respect and
honesty and sexuality and all of that
stuff while also being vastly
entertaining one hopes one well it was
it was sort of dating to me I keep
talking about it now so easy
I can cancel off the yes well yeah
getting getting on ten years since we
started it pretty hasn't started and the
one of the things that I gravitated
towards it the most was our man-eating
chain yeah he used the greatest it was
the first experience ever had writing
apart for someone and getting that
person it was just you know I imagined
it like I had his voice in my head cuz
who's not the biggest I put band the
world and yeah it was it was one of the
craziest times of my life because it was
just it was so fun and so rewarding
making this show that I just there was
nonsense I mean it was bananas to even
try it
like I want to do modern she address
Shakespeare but with the Bible and there
are certain cultural and Evald abilities
that are going to always play out no
matter what timeline you're in but it's
not here it's not now and it's not the
future by the way don't tell that di
McShane he still thinks it's future
America behind just market it that way
and and on working with Ian McShane and
Francis Lawrence directed it and the
pilot in the first two episodes shot in
New York it was a wonderful time in my
life I never it was it was the first
time I just really felt like creatively
fulfilled being in charge of something
and working with wonderful people and
learning from them running a show the
first time and going like okay I don't
know a lot that's fine I'm going to ask
stupid questions and lose credibility
which are which I still do that's my
show anxiety great show like ultimately
like whatever whatever gets you the good
show
whatever Gavin is a good show and yeah
it didn't work but NBC did let us finish
it away wanted to never killed the but
like they do a third regime came in and
we're just like you know just
slaughtered everybody and but at some
point I got a call going all right look
we're not going to kill your buddy we
were shooting are like second last
episode so just finish it out basically
saying we'll declare a victory if it
works but we're not going tell me when
you're on which in network television
land is considered favored take this
it's a secret it's a secret between you
and your fan yeah yeah but it was a I
would do it all over again knowing Advil
so let's follow them exchanged thread
the Machane thread so I loved working
that me was great he decided to trust
like me if you know of all people they
always think coming off militaries like
alright so your
that was what 34 you know and they all
right
you seem note you're doing and we got a
we and we continue to get on we always
kept in touch here and there you know
the Audion le odd how you doing and then
cut to a series of adventures later
Brian fuller of hero season 1 Fame who
is a dear friend and as talented writers
there is it's a shame he's not here
because he's just a much better
interview than I am new not so yourself
short you're he's also incredibly tall
and me standing next to him like unlike
master-blaster with him but I'm happy
right now we're like hey we're just two
guys thank you guys
but Brian had been involved in American
Gods he'd met with me on Neil Gaiman and
Fremantle they were interested in having
him run it and he was going into a
surprise third season of Hannibal Brian
and I had met a million times between
ears and then just catching up always it
I'd just word for each other I love his
work he's we're mutual fans and but you
know the idea that like it would be
great to find something to work together
on again was always appealing because we
just liked we always jog well and called
each other you know what do you think of
this kind of relationship and we just
met like a week before you know sugar
fish LaBrea and no he's one Beverly
Hills it's important detail yeah we're
doing sort of which of the douchey la
franchise fish places ideality yes we
were at and we don't he called up me up
and was like so I was going to do this
and I need a partner and I we it would
be fun and I'm like I like do you know
he's a dunno American Gods I'm like do I
not good I don't really God and of
course it was an easy thing to say even
if I didn't I would have been glad to
deal with Brian but I love that book
I've been waiting for that to come up
for years and yeah so we've been working
on that so cut to like a year-and-a-half
development on that and we're working on
the episodes with his Orissa sirs and
cheering about during Bobby's the Slavic
god of death and we're imagining who
would should we write this for and I'm
like you know [ __ ] killed us as Ian
McShane or like yeah you know when we
get the script done and we're finally
ready to send out an offer which
do that and cut two extra months later
we're finally ready to put an offer out
and so I called his manager who have
always kept up with and she's like I
said left this for him let me send him
and she she's like he's gonna love this
he's gonna love us and she calls me back
next day so he doesn't look like a [ __ ]
she like call him though he wants to
talk to you and it's like hey good
Michael loves I'm just not feeling the
burn here thank you he actually said
that it was the time of Bernie but what
I got out of the conversation with him
and she said call me after you talk to
him was the back ended compliment is he
doesn't like this role because he leaves
and he was kind of going like what about
this mr. Wednesday and like this you
want to play Wednesday [ __ ] and like we
were down you know the rabbit hole of
casting on that who was on the Wednesday
list I shouldn't say nobody so just like
you know we were going like crazy
dreamland and we were going sort of like
what if he's you know just not we were
just all over the plate Will Smith right
you wanted what Smith for Wednesday he
was on a list there was more than one
Wednesday of color and just on the crazy
left and we were hearing at one point
that Nicolas Cage there was a point
where was he was on a list and we almost
met with him and I think that to be
honest that was the like weird alley we
were down because we kind of you know we
were just in a moment of like well we'd
have to rewrite significantly but it's
interesting and we're trying to make a
weird show so we just didn't week we
considered a lot of things I don't know
if it ever would have happened and he
put the brakes on it first going like I
shouldn't do it just because I like it
I'm not this person that you who knows
what his process was because flattering
he liked it and I'll continue to root
for that guy do so then you know when I
got that call about you and being
interest I said give me two days for
some [ __ ] shake out and let's talk for
real and things got very real very
quickly he signed on we met he had met
Ryan fuller they got on very well and it
was great to be working with him again
because he came with certain amount of
trust but I also you know work with the
end of Shane you got to bring you know
when the high heat you got to be ready
you got yeah you gotta have the height
you your scripts must be in line
everything must be in line he's he's an
old salt he knows when things are
writing things
so one of the things I wanted to talk
about was this this crazy year in
Michael Greene Jesus the year that
begins in February with Logan Federer
right yep
February Logan March American Gods then
you get May with alien covenant right
and then what do we get after that we're
getting played around late one or 2049
yeah in October and then murder legal
and Express yes
see November in November that that
that's a [ __ ] kind of stuff to land in
one calendar year they are all after a
fashion adapted one way or another what
is your way into an adaptation like how
do you approach is everything different
or is there a here's kind of my
checklist when I'm approaching a thing
that I'm going to um you know we you
treat each one differently
it starts with do you have a connection
to the material and think hard about
what that connection is because now you
have two obligations you have an
obligation there's a siren right now
you're spitting hot cakes my friend no
no no yes yeah um so you now have two
obligations one to try to present to an
audience of as many as possible what it
was that drew you to it and then
secondly for those who've never heard of
this how can you give them an experience
that approximates your own joy of this
thing so you're dealing with the people
who that's almost the same thing I
probably try that hot take one more time
you have to service the fans as best you
can but again you're only giving them
you can only give them your impression
of it each one you come out differently
because you you don't know well you
might be doing it by yourself or you're
coming in with partners already
sometimes you're working with material
that are exists you're rewriting the
script or you know robust novel or
you're working with the director as a
very clear vision I can you know each of
those projects had just a really
different development history somewhere
cleaning somewhere I was like the third
person you know each one had a different
set of
that created my experience on it and
then also screenwriting you go into
every project hoping it's a marriage
some you date for a while and you leave
acrimoniously that was none of those
some you date for a while and you leave
like hoping the best for them and you
got something from them and you hope
they got something from you and some you
marry and so some of those I saw through
to the very end you know American Gods
and the showrunner you know Blade Runner
I wrote it and you know based on a
treatment that was written by someone
else whose other conversation is
fascinating and adventure but then I
wrote that through the end but then you
give it over to you know a director and
a production team that are astonishing
and just be grateful for every minute
that but you don't see through the
details and to each one you're very
different was Learning Express so I was
the first and last writer on and but I
had a partner negative Christy and in
Kenneth Branagh so she's a [ __ ] you
know I look at Neil Gaiman zzyx pencils
it's okay it's just much easier when
they're dead sorry no that's not true
please he no keep your like we love
having him uh don't dine you please
don't die please don't never we need
maybe 90 more novels from you minimum
he's a member of like the Eldridge gods
anyway so he's never going that's you he
will come back as choked off pretty much
be perturbed so while these are all
heating screens in a counter year
assuming that the writing of this was it
was ongoing yeah it's a weird year by
any stretch you work on things for a
long time I mean to be honest I'm
actually nervous talking about it I
haven't the first time anyone's asked me
like the sort of putting in that I get
into like we've done a lot of American
Gods interviews or some loganing of
music um but the way like when I've
talked to friends about it always like
so how'd you get away with that and the
way I've gotten away with it it's like
it's you know if you want to get rid of
the murder don't tell me when you killed
somebody or as my father says you know
they can't shoot they can't see you know
so I've kept a low profile like what I
what I did for a long time I was I was
working on television development and
you know my MDB page is like a lot of
people like it suffers from long silence
and but during those long silences
usually when you're getting the work
done and so there's a long period where
wasn't shooting things and I was just
quietly like writing things for
different people and you know writing my
television pilots for Fox oh I owed them
two at the time who were great but you
know and you've had all that other time
and when you come off a network
television show that does 22 episodes
literally everything is easier so my
dream for myself coming off the network
television 22 episode thing was always
what if I could work 70 percent that
hard and do better and so I just took
some quieter time and just you know and
then and then you try to stack the train
cars so they don't collide but then
sometimes I do last year when we were in
production American Gods Fremantle and
stars are going to hear this and yes I'm
going but there were definitely times
you know I like gonna call like work is
needed on dis production and a
production like there were three
simultaneous productions of things that
I was involved with directly that would
occasionally call at the same time and
what's the line of enemies a love story
it's like you do the best they can
yeah but yeah it's it's strange talk
about because I'm worried I I don't want
to try to get away with that ever again
it wasn't it was hard yeah but it's not
I mean it was fun like you can't
complain like oh [ __ ] I got out stay up
late and work on Blade Runner night it's
fun it's play screenwriting is always
fun the only bummer is deadlines well I
don't know anything about this I thought
I loved this family the whooshing sound
yes the whooshing sound is delightful so
I know we can't talk very much about the
future the future Conan the future we
can't talk very much about it despite
the fact that which we just America now
features well the American Gods featured
I mean what's been the most heartening
response you've gotten off of American
Gods hardening apartment uh it's been
great the response has been better than
I expected to be honest because it shows
bananas well here's my new definition
bananas and bonkers like bananas
unexpected bonkers you're just like what
why would you do that
the show is bonkers and we love it
what's been great is that the audience
seems to
be interested in what we are interested
in about the show they've taken it as
sort of the pretentious art piece we
wanted but what's been most heartening
is the acceptance of the cast who are
wonderful and I adore the the acceptance
of the need for diversity in it you know
these are stories of immigrant tales and
largely even even the main narrative is
someone who's an immigrant into the
world of magic which is just even more
heavy-handed imagery for allegory for
what the show is about and we're in a
time where you know empathy towards
immigrants is epi low a painful low and
people we made the show under a
progressive administration and then you
know the American voting public ship the
bed and we ended up with what we ended
up with and done the opposite
yeah and so there was a moment there
where like all these immigrant stories
suddenly became politicized which we
didn't expect really in 10 but somehow
empathy became a political act uh which
is very strange and sad my [ __ ] thing
to be thoughtful and going to have
empathy for people is political exercise
so um the fact that the audience got
ahead of us on that and said it all for
us was really hardening because people
wanted that in respect to that and we
didn't have to say anything for that
message we just let the work stand and
they read into it and yeah more people
watched it and could play along with
that and we expected so we were thrilled
then you got picked up for a second
season relatively early on uh by some
show standards for us I'm sure yeah
we're like why did it take it himself
goddamn like they won is it do it have
you been to surgery um what what loose
plans do you guys have like how far
ahead of you planned for what the show's
glad well we have a bunch of different
decision trees that we look at and prune
from time to time nothing I could commit
you now we often talk about like you
know we have one novel it's not like
where you have a perspective imagine do
you guys have energy boys we do not have
nan see boys no boys owned by ku the
hotel knows I think we'd like to get it
I mean we'd love to do more but we can
see this show that book the novel
American Gods going three seasons four
seasons five seasons there's plenty to
mine in between their times you want to
slow down and their times are like oh
this shows hard let's just get to the
war um but we find ourselves very much
enjoying the journey as the cliche goes
but not without reason it's it's really
fun to make it's fun to explore its
length on just sit we're not you know
the rocket ride of a long-legged we just
want to Stampede to the clitoris and
just you know we kind of just want to
sit and how about a kiss blade like we
really love these deep dives into the
characters which are fun and always
casual week on fat man on Batman a
stampede to the clitoris for the Michael
Green hey mud Python exactly welcome
merit and what else do you have in the
future I know
oh no there's a thing you can't talk
about why the last man which Brian Avon
has talked about so you're not here not
here okay but he has in the world no I
ain't MX there's a draft that you've
written that at some point if all of the
planets align there there are a lot of
planets that need to align there's a
draft
with FX that they're a very smart group
and I really enjoyed like they I'm glad
that Brian cave on gave it to them and
said okay this is the place to make it
home and I came in after that because
that's I think the ideal place for it um
yeah here's open now there's there's
just a bit of development to do but it's
been like strikingly Pleasant everyone
involved just once like a really good
version that Joe it would be somewhat
ironic if you go into American Gods
thinking that you would be making it for
a during a progressive administration
yeah to then have the opposite to then
be making why the last man yeah about
the one dude in a world full of women
during this administration yeah it but
it could be released in the next one
which will be the [ __ ] like Garden of
Eden of awesome because the clap back
from this to that will be I was humans
you bees right like me
angry a show about the angriest people
and a vote on shiny happy utopia that we
all kind of wanted but never got yeah
yeah that's probably do another show
yeah why'd last night had to be very
considered and reconsidered after the
election because it became about
something very different to me actually
had a minute there were like oh I don't
open the writer for this in this world
and I had to figure out that but yeah
that's sort of we've got some future
time before that's at the catcher and so
I mean Jesus after this year the you
know I know it's all about American Gods
making season 2 if Murder on the Orient
Express goes well the detective goes
elsewhere ah new cute Wow yeah yeah
travels he does continuous travels it
was a great experience uh Fox was
wonderful to work with and I got oh the
manage Casas bananas I'm enraged yeah I
met yeah I made all kinds of people on
that it was cool um what it was a great
experience I mean as much as those
things are fun to like cast and recast
and like can we just put all these
people back and just put them in another
give me on a Greek island somewhere
under kill them yeah giving new fussy
British names that'd be kind of great
now like a repertory of people you're
going to kill every movie but we'd like
them enough to just buy it they're not
ever time this time no mustache
apparently that was Judi Dench's line
let's do this again in another movie but
this time I'll wear the mustache ah no
she has all of the awards so she just
she would ever say anything she wants
yeah um well yes [ __ ] awesome is
there anything that you would like to
plug any any anything you want the
slugged me more than I deserve I it's
because I like you you deserve a lot of
money yeah I'm good I'm shamed by
everything yeah yeah watch Deadwood if
you haven't wasn't it what I do die
really or watch it again if you it very
few shows why do you watch as much of
that yeah when we first met American God
right well that should probably watch it
whatever but we had talked about when we
first met sitting down I'm like what are
the stories from the Kings world that
you want to keep telling and you were
like well here's where season two would
have gone in season three would have
gone here's all the dreams that I have
they got crushed
yeah
will do there's a world in which you
could absolutely make a comic book of
kings that I think people would read I'm
going to put it out there to the world
at large publishers who may or may have
but if 40,000 people were like I'm not
the barometer for success you know what
comics and a barometer of success it's
you can't pay me enough to like revisit
a fail it has nothing to do with money
it's more just it hurts too much to like
go back and you know I have those
stories I love those stories but they're
kind of you just flee flee the fire
scabbed over it's sad I wish I could
have told them in a grander fashion alas
all right boys and girls that will be it
that is that we learn the podcast look
this is what the podcast says we talked
for a bit and then we just ended
abruptly and like unfair moneys I'm
surmising you can like no callback joke
like at the end of a stand-up it and
that would slide far too much
preparation alright something actually
you could just put that down but I will
then say goodbye to the boys and the
girls that's been this episode of
feminine I'm Batman I'm mark Barnard
this is Michael Green stay tuned next
week for another st. fat time same fat
place and they sustain all this because
Kevin usually does the heavy lifting and
he says go to SModcast comm and I say or
youtube.com to Kevin Smith but it's
weird I'm doing all the work come back
Kevin I miss you I love you you're my
I'll be right here Oh
[Music]
[Applause]
you